this is Jocko podcast number 170 with
echo Charles and me Jacques are willing
good evening echo good evening it is
time for some Q&A okay
it has been a while yeah it's been a
while for sure
so let's questions yeah from the
interwebs yes indeed as it is sit okay
first question
Jocko I'm taking over leadership of a
team of six people - I know
and four I don't when you've taken over
leadership did you one give a group talk
to meet with each individual and three
what did you say good question yes
obviously give a group talk that's
affirmative you get everyone together
hey guys my name is Bill mm-hmm I came
from this place I'm here to take over
now there's a some judgment calls that
you have to make because you're gonna
introduce yourself but if you're taking
over a well-functioning team then guess
what you're not going in to revamp
everything immediately because
everything's going fine so hey I'm happy
to be working with you guys looking
forward to it I know you guys have a
great reputation glad to be a part of
the team awesome if you have any
questions let me know I'm here that's
easy if you're taking over a team that's
not working well like there's problems
and that's why somebody got fired and
that's why you're coming in there you
might need to address some of those
things hey listen I know things have
been a little off track I'm gonna look
at what's going on I'm gonna take input
from you guys we probably need to make
some changes we're gonna do it together
as a team that's where we're moving from
here we need to get back to where we're
supposed to be boom something like that
and again there's gonna be people on
that team that have been busting their
ass and working really hard and if you
go in there and just disparage everyone
there you're gonna start off on the
wrong foot
so yeah have keep it pretty broad when
you meet the whole group hey this is who
I am this is where I came from this is
what I'm looking forward to all that
stuff
and then yes do you meet with the people
individually absolutely you go around
you meet with them and when you what do
you talk to him about you talk to him
about them I'm talking about them you
want to know about them you want to know
who they they are you want to know what
they're for what the family situation is
what their interests are what's going on
how they feel about the transitions that
have been taking place a little bit of
that stuff it's not about you it's about
them so go yes and talk to everyone take
notes maybe not right in front of them
so you look like a nerd but you know
afterwards you go hey Bill has three
kids his wife also works at the company
he's interested in soccer and basketball
whatever you just take those notes you
know it's actually good before you take
some Sun over a situation if you already
familiarized yourself with us you look
at them maybe the HR website at your
company has a picture of everyone so you
kind of know who they are
gives you less stuff to remember so
there's that make good first impression
don't go in there looking like an idiot
don't go in there thinking that oh I
just I'm the boss man so everyone has to
bow down and and bow down to my
superiority no they're actually mad at
you but the thing is they're mad at you
so I remember one time I was taken over
a small element and one of my friends
was a part of the element and I went in
like 20 guys I went in hey and I walked
in but I just had a notebook with like
five things I wanted to talk to them
about
mm-hm and as soon as I walked in i
opened up my notebook and he said
something like you brought a notebook
you're always squared away that's why
you're putting in charge that's why your
boots are so like just a little
impression of hey man I'm I take this
stuff seriously and I would say overall
your main goal when you're meeting your
team when you're meeting the individuals
on your team is you are looking to build
relationships with the people on the
team that's what your goal is because
when you build these relationships
that's what's going to make your team
stronger etc yeah remember the time you
want when you're on Joe Rogan the first
time when he was like hey you're the
only once
who've ever brought a note pad yep and
you're like just trying to be prepared
just trying to be prepared it's good in
case there's anything you know yeah it
comes up do you want to slip your mind
yeah yeah that that's funny and I'm
trying to imagine being a worker and you
know when you get a new manager you know
whatever new boss um you know they come
in yeah if they're I like having the
individual meeting I would out dig it
and then but if they're like taking
notes I'd be like wait why are you take
you know it's like well how are you
gonna use this yeah you know against me
later what if hey hey man how's it going
how long you been here for oh I've been
here for four years
aw cool do you you are you married yeah
yeah I got two kids oh that's awesome
that's awesome how long you been married
for oh six years like that you don't
even know the person if I go in there
and I go how long you been here
and you're like six years and I write
yeah write it down I say what what what
is your primary function here at the
team you know what I mean if you just
jump right into that oh yeah we're not
looking to build a relationship we're
just looking to find out how I can use
you yeah that's what it feels like I
mean you said it like you'd be married
you said it like that no man doesn't
matter how you say you could say it the
most nice polite way ever and when you
write it down it's kind of like bro like
are you gonna take all this information
and sort of do some sort of evaluation
for you you know kind of it's what it
feels like it does feel like that that's
why I specifically said when you're
having a personal conversation with a
person that you're meeting for the first
time you're not scratching you didn't do
a notepad yeah now that being said if
the guy says you know what I've noticed
some things here around here that need
changing you go really hold on a second
yes let me break out my notebook here
and take notes on what you're about to
say that's advanced you know it's like
when you get a micromanager you're
working for a micromanager bring a
notebook they see you writing stuff down
they think it's they're like happy yeah
trick anyone yeah cuz well cuz when
you're writing down their stuff
yeah lips the skirt it's like it makes
it like oh yeah yeah he's taking notes
it's important what I'm saying yeah yeah
like you can evaluate like my opinion oh
happy yeah that's good roll in there
with the book it's like the doctor you
know when you go to the doctor and he's
asking you oh yeah like all the stuff
you see them writing down
you know in your chart whatever even
though doctors did you is just good cuz
you want him to go evaluate it later
I'll give you a cure but same deal man
same deal here for those notes and my
sake jack-jack that comes not prepared
for you to take notes on a week now how
long you been married
Oh nine years old nine years next
question next question is are Junt and I
want to know how to deal with my men in
a way without punishment
but still make them better for next time
okay here's something for you
punishment is actually the last straw in
how you deal with people that you're in
charge of in fact I will tell you this
if I ever had to punish someone when I
had to administer punishment on my
troops I always felt that I had done
somewhere I had done something wrong hmm
right like even if a guy got in trouble
out in town got drunk got in a fight did
something stupid I would still look at
that and think to myself how could I
have allowed this guy to not realize
what a disaster it is how much trouble
he's gonna get in what kind of
international incident he's gonna cause
how that's gonna hurt us in the team
strategically are all those things how
did I let that happen
so doling out punishment is not optimum
I mean you've you've pretty much you've
pretty much made a mistake if you have
to punish people because if you're doing
if you're being a good leader people are
doing what you want them to do there's
no reason for punishment
so that's what you should not be looking
to punish and just like I just said you
should be looking to build relationships
you should be looking to show people a
better way of doing things a way that's
more smooth and more efficient it
doesn't disrupt what the team efforts
are you got to explain to people why
they're doing what they're doing this is
all stuff right this is you explain why
things are done a certain way
explain how it impacts the team explain
how it impacts them that's also
important you've got to have people
rehearse in in retrain because now now
I'm talking about how do you get people
to do the right thing
right without punishing them so we're
trying to avoid punishment how do we
avoid punishment
training how do we avoid punishment by
people understanding what they're doing
why they're doing what they're doing how
do we avoid punishment by setting goals
that make sense that are small enough
for them to get to and then have fun
with the goals and get in the game
yourself and show them that you're not
perfect and that is what you need to do
you need to make every effort to make
people understand why they're doing what
they're doing how they fit into the big
picture and when they figure all that
stuff out and they're on board
you shouldn't have to punish people you
shouldn't have to punish people so I
know it's yeah that's what it is
your sergeant and you want to deal with
your men away without punishment well
think of what the mistakes you're making
when you're when you're when your fire
team or your your your platoon does
something wrong why did they make that
mistake they make the mistake cuz they
wanted to mmm no they made it because
you were a bad leader at that point in
time you what could you do better hey
guys where what didn't you understand oh
you guys messed up this training
operation I'm gonna restrict your
weekend duty I'm gonna restrict you to
weekend duty meaning you can't go out in
town what good did I just do mmm right
are they gonna try harder now mmm right
now but if you say hey listen guys we
did a bad job I know I must have made a
mistake in trying to explain this
information to you all because we didn't
do what we were supposed to do let's
look let's dissect this thing as a
matter of fact let's spend Friday night
dissecting this thing I'm buying pizza
and we'll sit around the the sand table
and we'll figure out what we did wrong
hmm that's not punishment mmm that has
the opposite effect of punishment that
has hey I'm bringing everyone in because
I want to win I want us all the wind so
that's what you got to do don't
punishment should be punishment should
be I mean do you have to punish people
sometime yes yes you do when they're
blatantly out of line when they do
something that's blatantly wrong yeah
you got to drop the hammer on them you
got
at the example sometimes hey you're not
gonna get away with this sometimes that
happened in the teens you know somebody
would do something stupid and the
command would just drop the hammer and
everyone goes man that guy got a DUI and
they you know docked him dig dig busted
him in rank and they pulled him out of
his platoon and they're sending him to a
to a fleet billet for two years but oh
my god that might make someone think
right you know maybe I won't step behind
the wheel
yeah so sometimes you do have to punish
if people do something stupid especially
after the being warned a couple times
yeah but I always look if I have to
deliver punishment on to my team I made
a mistake somewhere I don't like it yeah
don't they say that the like reward and
encouragement is like way more powerful
and punished definitely way more
powerful
I've almost never punished people yeah
yeah but the reason is why did I punish
people because people were doing weren't
doing stupid things they were doing what
they were supposed to be doing they were
doing yeah I mean I probably I don't
even know if I I probably I think I had
like one or two captain's mast where I
had to bring somebody in and drop the
hammer on them that's because they did
dumb stuff mm-hm
like yeah you know what you can't do
that I didn't think of it I'm sorry but
you can't do that possessions yeah
next question Jocko in the discipline
equals freedom Field Manual the section
fear reads how do you overcome feel fear
of failure step go but a previous entry
reads I don't want you to overcome fear
of failure I want you to be afraid of
failure my needing yeah clearly there's
a dichotomy here
I know it's my favorite word apparently
according to Dean Lister yes okay there
is a dichotomy here because fear is
something good that you should take
advantage of so it's kind of good to be
afraid because it keeps you on edge
adjectives
it keeps you preparing as much as you
possibly can and all that stuff is good
but at the same
yes if you go too far to the other end
of spectrum fear gets ahold of you you
can't overcome it so you freeze or you
cower or you run away and none of those
are good reactions so what I obviously
failed to communicate well in the book
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
is the dichotomy between these spectrum
the spectrum of fear that you can have
so if you have no fear whatsoever no
fear well guess what you get cocky you
can get arrogant if you have too much
fear you can't even get out of the gate
you just freeze you hesitate so like all
dichotomies you got to balance those two
that and the way you balance those two
is to try and do things that make you
feel fear right try and do things that
that make you feel fear mmm so that way
you get used to it you can over comment
you can deal with it you can utilize it
if you have a fighter
you ever hear UFC fighters I become
afraid every time I get in the ring yeah
pretty much everybody yeah pretty much
everybody I'm afraid cuz you're you
afraid you're gonna get knocked out
you're afraid this you're afraid that
afraid I'm gonna lose in front of all my
family and friends and all that so
everyone's afraid so what does that fear
do it drives you to train harder drives
you prepare drives you to keep your
hands up and your chin down when you're
in the cage right so yeah there's a
healthy level of fear it can also get
get the best of you so keep it balanced
yeah we talked about this and I think
Sam Harris talked about it first for the
first I heard it made a point not to go
too deep into it but the where you know
like this okay fear how do you overcome
fear step go right it's essentially like
take action be brave in the face of fear
yeah but if there's no fear it's kind of
like you're not really being brave
you're not you know kind of thing well
that's true yeah so could consider that
that notion yeah all right so you say
yeah I want you to be afraid of failure
oh yeah be afraid of failure but you've
still got a step you still gotta go you
still gotta be brief you know kind of
thing so they do actually kind of
complement each other really unless you
think like oh yeah overcome fear meaning
like I'm not scared of it anymore it's
literally not figured it's always fear
but it's more it's less about the fear
you know it reduced to zero it's more
about being brave training yourself to
be embraced with your here yeah
embrace the fear and the and so to
continue with that thought in order to
embrace the fear what do you do you step
do you go into it so there you go
there's your answer question I was
wondering when does standing up for the
right thing take precedence over
avoiding conflict this is something that
leaders have to deal with all the time
so clearly out of the gate things that
are immoral unethical or illegal if you
participate you're guilty that's the way
it is now things that are a matter of
opinion
that's where you might have to play the
long game like maybe you won't want to
do something a certain way and if you
but if you think oh well I think the
jiu-jitsu class warm-ups should be doing
these exercises and in EKKO thinks it
should be those exercises so EKKO these
things we should do it this way no we
should do it this way you dig in I dig
in now we weeds to end up saying well
I'm not gonna teach the class you know
you end up in these situations well
what's the big deal what's you know what
I'd rather do I'd rather play the long
game I'd rather say hey man can you
explain why you do those exercises oh
here's another exercise cool and that I
learned isn't this good for this
technique oh you know how you like when
I do this move this actually helps me do
it even though it's just a warm-up move
oh that's cool we build a little
relationship you get to understand me I
get to understand you boom Yeltsin you
say hey I'm gonna incorporate that into
our warm-up so we're gonna want to up
here pull ya like that there you go now
I understand that that's the right thing
right because in my mom I'm on in my
mind I'm thinking hey these students
didn't know this escape it's the right
thing to do so I do that so you have to
weigh it out what am i doing to my
relationship in this situation if I go
along with this like if you ask me to do
nine things that are pretty menial and
you're my boss and I said yep cool got
it boss no problem
and you ask me to do something else's
meal yep cool got it boss no problem
then you ask me to do something else me
no cool got it boss no problem then you
ask me to do something that's downright
stupid and dangerous like oh hey boss I
need to talk about this I'm not sure can
you explain to me why we're doing it
this way because there's a
boo that someone could really can hurt
you all well you've done you're in your
mind you're thinking you've done these
ten things for me you've done nine
things from you've done seven things
from you did them well you didn't
question me and novice and you have a
question you must have a legitimate
question that's what we're hoping for
that's why we're trying to build
relationships now all that being said
yes we're playing along it there are
times and this is a really sketchy area
to enter into there are times where
something that is happening is immoral
unethical or illegal and you might
actually have to kind of go along with
it I tried to think of a good example of
that and I thought of one Oskar
Schindler and from Schindler's List what
did this guy do right this guy was a
Nazi he was a Nazi they were
exterminating Jews and instead of him
standing up and saying this is wrong to
exterminate Jews I protest how long
would he have lived if he had done that
30 seconds right there oh you know you
don't think Jews should die Cole we're
killing you that was that how many
people did he save zero in fact he costs
he went negative one yeah what did he do
he played the game he he befriended the
Nazi leadership he bought them gifts he
bribed him he bought him gifts he built
relationships with him he ended up being
able to move his factory and all this
other stuff to save a bunch of Jewish
people and he even though he knew like
he would he would see them executing
people he would to see them executing
Jews and he knew it was wrong he thought
it was wrong he felt it was wrong and if
he would have stood up and said hey what
you're doing is wrong then he wouldn't
have been able to save anyone he would
have been killed himself so even in that
situation it's it's not a guarantee that
you you need to stand up to do the
ethical thing because perhaps there's a
chance you can do the more ethical thing
by playing the game building
relationships who knows who knows maybe
if that war went on maybe
would have said oh you know what he
maybe he would have risen to a position
where he you know maybe if the Germans
what I want and he could have said hey
you know what the Jewish people are
making good workers here I'm gonna I'm
gonna continue to use him or whatever
you know maybe he builds up a whole new
you never know but when you get rid of
your influence when you lose your
influence because you stand up it might
not be the best move and the thing that
you have to wait for this what you have
to weigh with this is you are
participating and actually you know they
say Oskar Schindler felt completely
guilty because he did participate and he
was a part of of what was happening you
know he did his best to stop as much as
he could but he wish you would have
stopped more and you know at some point
maybe you see a little six-year-old girl
getting shot do you think you know what
I should screw it I should stand in
front of that bullet and take that
bullet for that little girl you know
that's the kind of guilt that he felt so
there are times where you really have to
weigh this out and also I'll tell you I
mean even in things that aren't this big
ethical dilemma head-on conflict is
generally not the best way to solve
problems most of the time it's much
smarter to maneuver it's much smarter to
flank and it's much smarter to come from
another angle
and it's much smarter to build
Allegiance and alliance with people so
you could have influence over them so
you can move them in the right direction
yeah so almost like I'm actually
straight up we're doing the right thing
and avoiding conflict is kind of like
they're not that like opposite you know
we're doing they're avoiding that you
should and I'm totally just interpreting
this trying to anyway avoiding conflict
you should always be essentially trying
to avoid conflict as far as that maybe
now that's not always okay generally
speaking we do a better job you know the
outcome is better when we avoid conflict
now of course anyone listening to this
thinks oh you take that to the extreme
this is someone that never stands up for
anything yeah you know and that's bad
that's all that's also
from a leadership perspective if if your
team is looking at you and they think
Jacques would never sticks up for us he
never gives the boss any pushback so we
just we're just at the whim of this
tyrannical boss and Jacques no buffer to
it that's what they see so you can't
just be a pushover but at the same time
if you go to your troops you say hey
listen guys here's what's going on the
boss has got a lot of ideas right now
some of them are good some of them not
so good but guess what
well what I'm doing right now and the
reason that we're pushing hard to carry
out what he's trying to get us to do is
to the best of our ability the reason
we're doing that is because I'm actually
trying to build some trust with him so
that he will listen to me right now he's
not really listening to me he knows I
don't have much experience but I'm
trying to build relationship so he can
listen to me so we can actually do this
and what I think it's gonna be a smarter
way can you guys help me build this
relationship by kicking ass for the next
three projects that we've got so I can
build up some clout and come back to him
and get the tools or the people or
whatever it is that we need yeah you
always have this real finesse sort of
way of saying stuff like you its
Footwear I guess you were like you were
saying and I think you were wrong
actually you were saying that that
standing up and doing the right thing
is the same thing as avoiding home as
avoiding conflict yeah no I didn't mean
it like that
I meant that they're not necessarily
always opposites you know like doing the
right thing in avoiding conflict like
they're you know there's just some
wishy-washy kind of room in the wiggle
room in there a lot of times and when I
say avoiding you should always be
quote-unquote avoiding conflict I meant
of course not always but I meant more
like even if I'm gonna confront someone
or something about like something that's
wrong I still should be while I do that
I should be avoiding like conflict
for sure do it in a finesse sort of way
to actually just keep everything you
know rolling forward maybe just nudge it
in a different direction kind of thing
but I actually now that I'm sort of
reading this again I understand what
he's asking you know it's like is there
a time where it's like hey there's gonna
be conflict is there a time where it's
worth the conflict and where is that
point you know the point that I always
give is if
if you're telling me hey Jocko go do the
mission this way and I'm like you know
what I'm not doing it yeah and you go
okay find your fire
yeah and now do you put someone some yes
man in my place and then that yes-man
gets everyone killed because it was a
stupid stupid plan did I really help or
should I have said hey boss and we're
really gonna recommend we do in a
different way here's some different
options and then finally you say no
Jacque are you doing it my way and guess
what even then I can go out and mitigate
in the field yeah even then I can say
you know what and the classic example
that is in band brothers when dick
winners the awesome leader they send a
recon mission across the river one night
someone dies they come back the war is
over it's all but over and the next
night they wanted to do another
reconnaissance mission and dick winters
is like sir I'm not sure that's a great
idea it's like do it he goes okay Roger
that the guys go down they drink a
couple bottles of wine in the bottom of
ugh they don't do the mission he
mitigated the risk if he would have
stood up and you know that's that's a
great example of where he avoided
conflict he stayed in the game he wasn't
he said yes yes sir
got it we got it and then he did
disobeyed sure he put his he put his
rank at risk and probably could have
gotten in some trouble but he knew was
the right thing to do yeah that was like
the best sort of way to do yeah man and
again you you're always thinking of like
the long game versus the short game you
know where it's like and you can keep
that in perspective these things become
a little bit more clear you know they
always do sir all right next question
Jocko I recently interviewed for a team
leave job but wasn't selected because I
don't have leadership experience how can
I lead what I'm not in charge well
you're in charge of something you're
certainly in charge of something you're
in charge of some piece of gear you're
in charge of some task you're in charge
of maybe a couple people here there but
even if you're not you're in charge of
something so whatever you're in charge
of take charge of it take charge of
whatever your task is you take charge of
it you own it you do it to perfection
that once you've got that completely
dialed then you know what you reach out
and you see who else you can help you
help with other tasks you
for work if you look for work you're
gonna find it but you're gonna find it
you're gonna find it you're gonna start
taking things from other people now what
you have to be careful of is that you
don't step on toes right because just
about everyone think about this just
about everyone is offended by someone
that wants to be in charge hey let me
let me let me take charge of this here
makes people cringe take lead on this
you know what hey listen up guys right
if you're that guy then everyone goes
hmm now there's a key point this this is
beautiful this is beautiful so let's say
we're in a platoon there's something
going on um in a mid-grade position and
I realize like I want to be a leader
right now if I just go any guys hey guys
let me run this next mission people like
do what do you know what are you talking
about you don't know anything hmm
okay and they're and they're kind of dug
in against me by the way at that point
yeah if I give it a knife I let things
escalate a little bit what I would
usually do is I would I would let things
escalate to a point to where when I took
charge people were waiting for it and
they were happy that I took charge then
that even I was even though I was
tasking the commander like if you're
tasking the commander okay so I got
lathe and stone are working for me
I'm tasking a commander we're out on an
operation something starts going wrong
right let's say Leif's doing a building
clearance with his platoon something
starts going on I jump down there and
say all right guys push it over that way
start clearing that hallway how does
they feel yeah kind of yeah fees he
feels like I jumped down and micromanage
his platoon and why are you doing this
everything was going fine so I don't
want to do that I want first of all I
want him to work things out of course
so what let's say same things happening
things are going a little bit bad
they're starting to be a little bit of
confusion they're starting to be
escalated voices they're starting people
you know hey wait wait no don't go there
you can hear it it's really obvious when
things are going wrong I might let that
escalate a little bit let it get to a
point where the Lafe knows he doesn't
have control of us anymore now I come
down to go hey everyone lock it up
you four hold on that hallway you to
start clearing that back room everyone
else get to the rooftop alone security
you what everyone thinks including life
thank God that just happened right now
and that can happen from anywhere in the
chain of command I'm happy I happen to
be given an example of when I was the
tasking commander but I would do the
same thing when I was a an e5 which is
oath ings are going a little bit
sideways no one wants to hear the guy
that as soon as that opportunity as soon
as there's any void of leadership you're
just like jumping in there like okay
guys Captain America to the rescue right
you don't want to do that you want to
let that before I'll tell you what
happens if there's a little tiny void
that you try and jump into guess what
you're gonna do you're gonna bump into
everyone else that's that's in that void
it has to meet an actual void of
leadership
once that actual void of leadership
opens up and it's big enough you jump in
there and you and because you've
detached because you are detached
because you're watching it happen you
jump in there and you have so much
confidence in what you're saying you
have so much understanding of the
situation you look like a genius and
everyone's happy that you just did that
and by the way as soon as that problem
gets solved you step back out the
leadership void is closed up by someone
else and you're good to go
and next time people people will not be
surprised at all when something goes
wrong and you step in and you solve the
problem yeah so that's what you should
do you yes you want to be in charge yes
you should look for work but you can't
step on toes don't jump in every time
chance you get like Captain America I'm
gonna save the day no you're not
let there be a real problem assess it
from the outside and like I said you got
to be careful about being Captain
America you got to be careful about
being I'm gonna so I'm ready to stand up
every moment and that's a problem you
know it's a problem when someone when
someone's goal this is gonna sound weird
when someone's goal is to be a leader
right like my goal is to be a leader
like if that's what they're thinking
that's gonna that's gonna offend people
mmm it's gonna offend people cuz and
I'll tell you why it offends people to
rightfully so you know why it offends
people because what is it about
themselves it's about me I want to be a
leader I me me want to lead that's what
it's about and everyone recognize that
if what you really want to do is you
want the team to
win and you realize that sometimes
you're going to be in a supporting role
and sometimes there might be another
situation where you need to lead almost
hesitantly you know what leadership
needs to happen I'll go make it happen
because the team needs it to win I'm
here for the team so don't be the person
about yourself man we don't like that
person I don't even like that person as
much as I love people that want to step
up and lead I don't want that person
that's like looking for themselves yeah
sometimes you got to be following I want
someone that's like hey oh cool I got
your back don't worry about I'm over
here I'm over here part of the Train I'm
over you're clearing rooms oh wait a
second there's a leadership void and now
there's an actual problem going on oh
and then that person suddenly steps up
and solves a problem then goes right
back down to their level
awesome that's the person you want and
that's the person you want to be yeah
yeah you know like not either why I hear
it a lot nowadays with add value you
just want to add value so essentially
what you're doing if you're not a lip
situation it's like boom I'm gonna add
value so one okay we're gonna start with
my own role you know that's where I'm
gonna add the most value my own role but
if there's little voids in whatever
capacity that needs some value-added I'm
going to add that value we can't just be
piling on the value where it's not
needed you know don't don't pour our
additional value into non value needing
areas exactly that's problematic too
much value it's true all right next
question hi Jocko when you're trying to
take ownership of a mistake made by a
fellow team member what do you do if the
team leader asked for a step by step
step by step breakdown of events I've
said it was our mistake and not to n-not
made excuses but a step by step
breakdown would expose the fact that he
alone was responsible for that error
interesting so he basically that's
interesting it is wait wait so he's been
saying okay it's our mistake right I
don't want to individualize this guy or
so you know make him stand out or
whatever it's our mistake and we're
gonna fix it kind of thing and he's like
no I want to step by step but the step
stuck step by step is gonna reveal ready
the solo actually bills fault and now
what I tried so hard to take ownership
but here it was actually bill that was
all Jack yeah actually not my it's
exactly not my fault is what we're
saying it's it's the truth right you get
that right yeah guys check it out who's
responsible when you're taking ownership
for something when you're taking extreme
ownership for something whose fault is
it mine
yeah sure does that include when someone
else on your team makes a mistake yes
but how can that be good if you seem so
let me ask you these questions here's
what I'd be thinking the teammate was in
error why why did the teammate make a
mistake why didn't the teammate have
backup why didn't the rest of the
members of the team why didn't I
actually go through with him and make
sure that he knew how to do that
procedure properly he's part of my team
we were responsible for this taking
place I knew he was a little bit shaky
and I didn't do anything to fix it
that's why it's our fault it's not our
fault because we say oh it's our fault
but it's really Bill that's not that's
not what we're talking about the point
is the point is to actually own it so if
my coworker fails
I'm literally saying to myself what
mistake did I make that my coworker
dropped the ball what mistake did I make
my coworker dropped the ball what
mistake did I make did I not show it to
him did I not ask him if he knew how to
do it did I not ask him if he needed
some help did I not confirm that he knew
the procedures correctly all those
things are my fault did I not do a good
job of identifying that Bill's a little
bit slow on the uptake and therefore he
needs a little extra preparation for
this and now now think about this what
can I do once I make this mistake
we're gonna do fix them and now think
about this from a leadership perspective
you go down and you say hey guys you
guys messed up this thing why did it
happen now think about the team where
everything goes well you know it's our
fault
mostly bill right and I'll tell you when
I when when when I look at a platoon and
bill made a mistake I don't look at bill
a good leader doesn't just look at bill
a good leadership looks at everyone on
the team especially certainly the
leadership and I think this guy's
talking about from a peer but it doesn't
matter from a peer perspective if
there's a mistake that happens we are
truly responsible and then from a
leadership perspective when I go down to
the team and I say hey guys what
happened and they said well it was our
fault but this is what Bill did I okay
so you just drop a dime on bill I'm not
gonna say that okay so it's all bills
fault cool I'll tell you what whereas if
you say hey listen bosses what happened
here's the procedures we went I don't
think we did a good job a briefing bill
cuz here's what bill did he did step
three instead of step four my fault we
went through twice but I should have
gone through it a couple more times and
confirmed he knew what was going on it's
not gonna happen again we got this which
guy you want to work for which guy to
you which which team do you want you
want the team where people are taking
ownership of the problem not blaming
bill ownership is not just saying we own
it ownership is actually owning it and
that's what makes it so powerful what
makes it so powerful is if you actually
own it then you actually look at bill
beforehand and you go look at our team
do we have any weaknesses yeah we did we
got bill bill doesn't bill can't get
this part of the procedure done right
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
put bill into this other position that's
an easier part of the procedure we're to
make sure he knows how to do that
meanwhile we're taking Mike and Mike is
gonna go down here and he nails this
procedure and he's gonna spend by the
way an extra 15 minutes a day during
lunch he's gonna get bill trained up so
bill can eventually that's the kind of
thing you do on a team yeah you made it
pretty clear which is which is kind of
because it's not that easy to understand
or it wasn't for me
I mean it would put it this way it was
it was very valuable one I didn't
understand this about extreme ownership
I said this before too by the way so
there's there's essentially two parts of
it that make it extreme ownership well
actually there's three there's the
dichotomy but aside from the dichotomy
this is what it is you take
responsibility and then you say what
you're gonna do to fix the problem and
then actually there's a third part which
is you implement the solution yes yes
okay you identify it you own the problem
you identify a solution for the problem
and then you implement the solution yes
that's what you do yeah so a lot of
times it'll be a session in the
beginning like I would just as far as me
just kind of casually trying to
understand it I would focus so much on
taking responsibility you know it's my
fault you know kind of thing it's like
well the taking responsibility I mean is
arguably more important than saying that
it's your fault kind of thing it's
essentially you're taking responsibility
of the solution as well yeah I know if
not you cuz in a way in a lot of
practical cases you don't even have to
identify whose fault it is if you take
responsibility of the solution like if
I'm okay here so if there's a football
team right that's like the epitome of
team not the epitome but what a good
example of teamwork never mind the SEAL
Teams or whatever but football is please
it'll be more simple because you sit so
let's say okay we got a pass or whatever
and boom the place the play starts and a
guy gets through the front line let's
say the guard missed a block obvious
right he missed it maybe he looked one
way and he was supposed to look this way
he was supposed to not pull any tried to
pull or something he just made a mistake
he just made a mistake he's not in
company just made a mistake whose fault
is it the guards fault okay but if the
quarterback is gonna take extreme
ownership he's gonna be like hey no
party the a this happened you know next
time we're I'm gonna remind them hey on
this play that play you know this red
forty six don't curve twist or whatever
you like you don't pull and he probably
like on men I know I know
don't go stall them just like a you
don't know ain't no problem but we're
just not gonna do that anymore and then
next time I call that play I'll be like
you're good right I'm gonna check with
them I didn't check whether than that
first time you made a mistake my check
with him he won't make that mistake
again I liked you when we were now being
whenever driving me you know yeah it's
kind of one of those things the
quarterback took responsibility for
solving the problem or so then he was
like okay Lutz that was my fault in
making a big deal out of it being his
fault no in his head it is you know it's
like okay this is my fault I should you
know I should make sure things are clear
kind of thing like the weather too you
know your weather yeah well what bothers
me the most about this question is I
feel like I feel like I don't do a good
job of explaining this because what bums
me out is someone whoever wrote this
question and it's a good question I get
the question I
I get scared that the person that's
listening the question goes no Jocko
doesn't quite get it he doesn't quite
get the fact that there was this one guy
who is part of the team who made this
mistake and no one you know we just we
can't hold his hand every time like
that's it's not my fault it's not our
team's fault when bill drop completely
drops the ball that's not my fault
it's not any one of the team's fault and
my point is is exactly what you are
saying echo yes it is and if you look at
it when Bill makes the mistake himself
he's alone in a room and he's supposed
to you know he's supposed to put part a
on top a Part B and bolt them together
that's his part of the job he's alone in
a room doing that and he doesn't do it
right that's 100% his fault the answer
is no actually who's in charge of
training him who's in charge of checking
who not even in charge of who's
responsible we are a team that means we
work together
that means we confirm that we know how
to do our individual parts of the job
that means we check and say hey bill are
you good hey bill let me check your
first three that you do to make sure you
understand what's happening we do this
together as a team and it makes me feel
like a failure that people have a hard
time understanding this and and I know
it's it can be a stretch it can be a
stretch and you know I give all those
examples
hey the machine gunner shoots in the
wrong direction whose fault is that it's
not the machine the machine gunner
literally pointed the machine gun in the
wrong direction pulled the trigger and
shot the wrong direction whose fault is
it
it's the squad leaders it's the fireteam
leaders
it's the platoon leaders because they
didn't make sure that he understood his
field of fire make sure he understood
how to operate his weapon and by the way
there's a chance that the reason that
bill screwed this up and Bill is
incapable of putting these parts
together correctly and if that is the
situation guess what is a responsibility
of the team to either get him trained up
to where he can't do it or to tell the
leadership that this guy cannot he's
incapable of doing the job and therefore
he needs to not be here mm-hmm
that's what ownership is that's what
extreme ownership is I think I know what
it is but what what makes it confusing
or sometimes kind of kind of slippery
like to grasp you know because it
depends on who you ask
so a lot of times the thing is when when
it's the machine gunners fault the thing
is if I'm if I'm not even a human being
I'm just a disembodied brain okay it's
the machine other's fault and the
leaders fault and that it's everyone's
fault if I'm dead you know but but if
you ask the individual person because
you ask the machine gunner hey okay
chocolate you're the machine gunner you
shot in the wrong direction and I ask
you whose fault is that what are you
gonna say now leaders well well if your
fault well let me let me tell you right
now there are plenty of people and
definitely plenty of machine gunners
that when they shoot that weapon in the
wrong direction you know what they say I
didn't get a clear brief on what the
field of fired work no one - I didn't
see the markers for what the range
limits were I didn't know where the
other blue forces were no one told me so
they're looking at it like it actually
isn't their fault now you get some good
machine and actually guess what when you
have a guy that's a machine gunner that
says what wasn't my fault it was my
leaders fault you know what the leader
says you know what the leader says well
good or bad leader the the leader in
this team the leader in this team you
know what he says no it was the machine
gunner swap yeah that's right now guess
whose fault it was it was no one's fault
yeah the Machine gotta think is the
boss's fault the boss thinks it was a
machine gunners fault now who's gonna
fix the problem the answer is no one no
yeah when you get a good team the
machine gunner goes my fault I should
have paid better attention that leaders
is my fault and now
have everyone taking ownership of the
problems yes yeah and that way it's
supposed to be but that's my point and
that's why it makes its nevermind your
disembodied brain that's making
decisions over here this is why it's
hard for people to understand that's why
sometimes and I'm with them I'm like I
was there it's kind of like it's kind
like you sure I'm trickin extreme
ownership you know the typical I'm
taking extreme ownership but at the end
of the day we always build for fault but
the reason that it is so hard because if
I ask ok we have three guys one of those
guys is a machine gunner the other guys
a leader the other guy is just another
team member he's you know he's did the
sniper
something if I say hey this machine that
I shot in the wrong direction individual
meetings they all take extreme ownership
all of them are down there in the game
yeah all of them I asked you machine
gunner whose fault is that what's he
gonna say - my fault ok next guy who's
faulted that fireteam leader my fault I
shouldn't tell them and their squad
leader my father should have told them
right yes so it the read now go back to
the disembodied brain it's kinda like
wait wait wait wait so it's like he did
it it's hard to grasp like that one guy
it is his fault thing is not just his
fault apparently because everyone said
it's their fault right so he was
obviously his fault but wait it's
everyone's fault kind of thing so when
you're the guy and you're saying okay
his fault in that little thing creeps in
your brain that's like yeah wait it is
his fault
yeah you know any and you're wrong yeah
yeah yeah and you're wrong and I need to
do a better job of explaining to Pete
that to people because I see questions
like this on a fairly regular basis
which is but hey really you know there's
okay I get ownership but really yeah
that's what I mean it's the but really
that you need to check yourself on yeah
because the reality is you're
responsible yeah you wait but what if
I'm responsible what about the Machine
he just said he's responsible oisin
gunner you're a boy I know but the
machine gunner said let see what I'm
saying though I think that's the feeling
that that Jeff you like creep in yeah
and that's gonna be a problem
yeah pray you ever seen office space
okay so really when you think about okay
what's the big thing I don't see as the
movie remember yes you know yes you okay
let me let me remind you kay so in the
beginning they were like hey Peter we're
putting cover sheets on the TPS reports
from now on or we've been doing that you
forgot to do that right so first
Lumbergh comes his pasta first Lumbergh
comes like yeah you know saying hey let
me read he didn't do it in a dick way
annoying for sure but he said hey this
is basically a reminder did you get that
memo we're putting cover sheets on the
TPS reports yes sir yeah I just forgot
it was a one-time thing no problem it's
like cool all you know so if you just do
that do that that'd be cool and he's
like cool no problem so I'll even give
you another copy of that memo he almost
like overdid it not almost he did overdo
it so he left and then the other boss
boom who's like one level down he came
same deal
hey we're putting did you get that memo
TPS reports cover sheets now table he's
like I got the memo I forgot one time
things like yeah I'm just all those
bosses were do doing just making sure
the problem got solved right doing
everything in their power even his
father his friends were like hey what's
up I heard you guys you're having
problems with your TPS so they were just
taking extreme ownership taking
ownership of the problem trying to solve
it but we give them crap about it who
doing it for the movie in a movie
somewhere yeah yeah because they're
trying to make it funny dude yeah I know
I know but that's kind of ironic but
yeah I know but it's ironic right it is
you know so I'm not even mad at Lemberg
for that the scene next question hi Jaco
I have a question for you I know you're
very busy guy how do you find time to
read so many books I have I have many
that I want to read but I've trouble
having enough time any advice on how to
set aside time to do so sure
make time
what do you what what are you doing all
day
the coccyx and what're you doing all
that are you watching TV are you surfing
the internet
are you watching YouTube videos that's
my question
what are you doing before you go to
sleep at night are you looking at
Twitter are you looking at Instagram
posts the Instagram videos tell me
they're not like an addiction yeah you
get the you get the the Instagram video
every one of them is funny they're 38
seconds long then 1 minute long get to
see people hurt themselves get to see
people do dumb things and make you feel
good about yourself mm-hmm I didn't do
that dumb thing someone else did
I can laugh at them how long you gonna
look at those videos for when you could
be reading so so there you go
stop wasting a bunch of time and then
what about audiobooks what do you have
what are you doing when you're mowing
the lawn what are you doing when you're
trimming the hedges what are you doing
when you're pulling weeds what are you
doing when you're cleaning the dishes
get some audiobooks get some audiobooks
what are you doing first thing in the
morning what are you doing are you
waking up checking your email sitting
around waiting you know wasting a bunch
of time are you getting up early enough
that you could just get up get out of
bed go and read for 30 minutes 30
minutes that's what you have to do you
have to make time there's plenty of time
to read there's plenty of time to read
you probably don't want to read as badly
as you're as you think if you wanted to
read that bad you'd make time you make
time to breathe somehow yeah well I can
make time to breathe you can make time
to read yeah well let's say list yeah II
would be a better one cuz like ya eat I
think because read you can read while
you're doing other things sometimes
especially with you just just kind of
like as a as a so I'm reading I'm always
have to be reading a book to read a book
for the podcast right yeah I had only
read
the first maybe 10 books that we read
that we did in the podcast we've done a
hundred or something now probably more
than that I had only read like ten of
them maybe it may be a few more but I'd
read them so long ago maybe I'd read 30
but I'd read some of them so long ago
that just I had to reread them and so
then you say to yourself okay so
whenever would you know when I read all
the time
I read go to bed good reading wake up
reading mm-hmm
going in an airplane LOC people what do
people do in an airplane you watch a
movie and oh you sleep they do all this
stuff
I sleep sometimes an airplane but from
not sleeping get us guess what I'm doing
reading forever for a broadcast I can
attest oh yeah what do you think is the
like the biggest ones that people are
you know that you know the biggest
activities they could yeah that they
could just stop and just for me I think
the biggest time sucks are YouTube I
think Instagram I think those two are
really what's the word stimulating to
the brain yeah and you actually get this
weird like well I actually like I'm
gonna learn a little something from this
right here I'm gonna take something away
from this I'm gonna veg out I'm gonna to
escape from my world right now
it's like escapism right yeah and and
they they actually have algorithms that
are that know what you will click on
they actually know that about you they
mapped your little brain and know that
if they put up a video that has if they
put up a thumbnail of a video and it's
got a heavy machine gun in it they they
know they got a good chance I'm gonna
click on it right and then they give it
a catchphrase title right you know they
give it a catchphrase title Isis gets
master
click uh 50 Cal versus Taliban oh cool
right yeah oh yeah yeah and after they
know us you're gonna click on ma'am and
that's that's so and what do you get out
of it you watch it for 20 minutes or
game yeah you get nothing out of it you
get a book you read you learn you write
something that's what you do yeah that
and actually the YouTube thing is it's
right if that's one of your things it's
worse than its it's not just YouTube
who's trying to get you to watch the
video it's the video makers themselves
so YouTube has the algorithm oh they got
it all kind of sorted out there and now
the video makers they make titles like
50 Cal versus XYZ and awful punches too
and guess what 50 Cal versus you can
fill in the blank you're probably gonna
watch that video motivation speech ever
yes yeah oh yeah so so in so destroys
whatever destroys reporter in interview
yeah exactly right so once it's really
owned actual basically right when you
log on to YouTube once YouTube pops up
on your screen bro everyone on that
screen is all sucking your attention
literally that's their job sucking your
attention so yeah man that's a big one
right Instagram so here's the here's
here's one that it really hit me really
hard a gram the gram oh and I like you
Instagram it's like good but if you're
like trying to read you know if you want
to read more or whatever consider like
even like let's say we start recording
this for a second we're looking about
our phones we're gonna maybe checking
email maybe we got a text or whatever
and the probability of Instagram coming
up on there we're gonna you know open it
but the probability of us opening
Instagram is it's pretty significant
it's pretty high and you can scroll
through there whatever even if you
scroll for two three minutes right you
scroll through there maybe what you
looked at 15 20 people's post read what
they had to say well if you have a would
you like Kindle or something right you
do that same thing it's like kinda end
the legacy and you
read yeah read instead so if you had a
camera like once you said like imagine
your video being videotaped like what if
you're being videotaped all day and all
I did was calculate every time you
opened up Instagram or Facebook or
Twitter and/or YouTube all those but
here every time we opened up but instead
and you had that scenario in one abridge
day then you take all that time and
replace it with you opened your Kindle
to read more bust out a book you know
you bring books or whatever with you and
that's how to instead of doing that you
did the book right you know much reading
you do right you'd read so much a lot of
reading yeah so it's like yeah those are
the time sucks man your phone it's so
available you know yeah what bright you
can read on your phone - mm-hmm that's a
big one GB - you watch TV not really but
I watch one show now and actually -
Hawaii five-o and that's it sometimes
Shark Tank that's it 100% it's weird
what is how often is a Hawaii five-o one
once a week and it goes in season so you
got how long is this season
I don't know thirteen episodes I guess I
don't know I know no but unless I have
watched one TV show recently it's called
billions there's a little scenario
unfolding on your billions all right
well show actually yeah and keep in mind
it's not like I've never seen any other
show ever and never will it's not that
yeah I think you know people they like
know much I don't routinely and actually
I will separate the fact that nowadays
you can watch TV in a different way
right it's not like at 8 o'clock on a
Thursday night you got to sit there and
watch it - yeah 30 minutes show with the
30 minutes worth of commercials in it
yeah right no you can you're you're on a
flight somewhere you've read you got to
take it easy on your eyes a little bit
if you start reading too much you've
read for a long time okay you're gonna
stare out the window for a little while
listen to this part of a podcast or
something then you're like okay my brain
is like barely functioning yeah okay
I'm gonna watch an episode of billions
yeah ballers everything ballers and I am
know the difference well I do know the
difference I watched that for a little
bit but me you know like people have a
routine like tonight you know every
night for 30 minutes they watch TV with
their kids or whatever it's like that
doesn't really happen anymore yeah next
question really sad how much time you
can waste these days with the
distractions and people trying to get
that time from you yeah your discipline
like when you when you first start
saying disciplining Cleo when I first
started hearing it from you
that was like one of the things that
popped into my head like as being really
obvious like if you are disciplined with
your time you'll have a lot of free time
like a lot a lot of freedom way more
than you would think anyway because you
know even when I'm like real busy you
know if I can accurately remember my day
I remember like just like five minutes
here 15 minutes there like that I did
something that was a waste of time and
if you add up all those little minutes
you have probably hours probably hours
four to do yeah do something per group
progressive you know productive work
nowadays progressive progress your life
valuable valuable all those things check
next question would you would your
extreme ownership philosophy have
changed or lost confidence if you had
been relieved of command when taking
ownership of friendly-fire incident you
described in your first book the book
extreme ownership by the way is just to
to be perfectly clear about this I
wasn't taking ownership of the
situations just so that I could keep my
job
it wasn't a political maneuver to set
myself up to look good I was taking
ownership of the situation because I was
the leader of the situation that took
place I was the guy responsible for what
was happening I was taking ownership
because that was the correct thing the
correct thing is something bad had
happened and I was in charge of it
and yes I could have been fired and if I
would have been fired I would have
accepted it and I wouldn't have done
anything different so again this is sort
of similar to a couple questions ago
like that's extreme ownership is not
about avoiding trouble it's not about
avoiding trouble you don't say well I
own it and then you don't get in trouble
you know you actually could get fired
you actually could get fired and that's
why that's why that idea of pre-emptive
ownership I talked about that at one of
the musters if if in the back of your
mind
if in the back of my mind I think you
know what if the platoon makes a mistake
I can just blame it on them I'll be good
well now I'm not really that worried
about their plan because I got that
little out if I need I'm not worried
about if the guys understand the rules
of engagement cuz I got that a little
out if I need it I'm not that worried
about deconfliction because I got that
little out if they screw it up so I
haven't out for myself and so I don't
really put 100% effort into the planning
and of the of what we're doing mm-hmm if
I have pre-emptive ownership which is
hey no matter what happens out here it's
my fault
guess what hey guys do you understand
that always let me talk to you about him
again hey hey laughs do you do you guys
understand where the where the lines of
limits of advance are so you know where
you get all you guys don't understand
hey do we see do we have it marked out
clearly okay great hey do you know like
dig in and when you dig in on stuff then
you have less of a chance of something
going wrong but when something does go
wrong and you take ownership of it you
take ownership of it not to avoid
trouble but to face trouble mm-hmm
that's what you have to do so my my idea
hasn't changed in fact if I would have
blamed someone else and then kept my job
and someone else gotten fired I would
have had a real problem with that I
could not have lived with myself
maintaining that position knowing that I
had sacrificed someone below me in the
chain of command for my own good
that doesn't sit with me man I wouldn't
been able to do that
I wouldn't been able to do that and
that's why when I was trying to figure
out who to blame it on because I was
because I was looking at this big
problem because a lot of bad things and
I'm saying to myself okay whose fault
was this and I couldn't figure out why I
didn't feel comfortable saying it was
this guy or was that guy it'd be like
this guy and the previous one guy said
well it's bills fault I don't feel
comfortable saying that especially when
I'm in charge and I don't feel come from
when I'm appear either if I'm if my peer
and we're part of a team and something
goes wrong I don't feel comfortable
saying it was the other guy hmm
who does that who feels good about that
right don't be that person and and not
only that when you're when you see
people acting that way everybody can
identify that that's a bad thing to do
yeah but they do it anyways because
their ego so keep it in check yeah
next question whether directly or
indirectly
I know Jocko follows this principle the
way you do anything is the way you do
everything this is an interesting I I
had to pull out because what you're
gonna see it's very I think it's
question maybe you might be even more
suited to answer than me we're gonna
head proceed interesting now let's say
you're sitting on the couch and you want
to switch the light on the switches to
your right and you know there's a 95%
chance that you can reach it from where
you're sitting without having to leave
the couch what do you do do you take the
chance to reach it or to reach for it in
vain and then get up walk to the switch
and turn it on or do you get up right
away and make the hand make the extra
effort and get it done in the most
efficient manner regardless of if there
was potentially an easier way yet you
know where you say I I know I'd love to
give some big profound answer about this
but here's the deal
I would accurately assess the distance
of light switch right oh accurately
accurately assess it and I'd figure out
the best way to turn it on and then I
turn it on that's what I do I mean if I
gotta get up outta bed eager to up gear
to get out of it yeah or I'd pull
pull we on the couch is that the
situation I'm gonna need the light on so
yeah all right get the light on my phone
out and see what I got to see with the
light because I'm thinking out of the
box over on my side well that's what I'm
doing what you do this as far as the as
far as the thing the way you do anything
is the way you do everything it's partly
true but at the same time guess what you
gotta prioritize and execute and and
there are some things that are not as
important as other things my famous
example is that my gym floor in my home
gym is not clean it's there's chalk on
it there's some sweat stains I don't go
in there three times a week with a mop
and swab it and get all the chalk out
and power wash it that's what it would
take maybe two times a week if I power
washed it pull all the stuff out of the
garage power wash the mats pull them
back in there set the garage back up
that's what it would take to keep the
mats clean that does I don't care if
those mats are clean or not doesn't
matter me right I have to prioritize
there's much much much more important
things than whether my mats in my garage
gym are clean doesn't matter yeah dude
you do mats are different right did you
sue Matt's got to be clean those guys
well we got people who clean those mats
after classes sure that's a priority the
ones at my house that just me don't
matter that doesn't mean that I'm
slacking in other areas Yeah right
there's a minimum standard in certain
thing like there's and even my home gym
mats I have a vacuum and I hate them
with the vacuum when I get too much dog
hair on them which actually I do that
like every one or two days and takes
three minutes to just vacuum dog hair
right but there's a minimum standard to
hold the line and as far as doing things
the most efficient way I try and do
things the right way
trying to do things the right way which
generally that coincides with the most
efficient way generally generally there
are but here that's not what he's
talking about here so what I'm saying
when you said I'm a fit down here's the
thing man bro this guy and you don't
we don't have this name but man we need
to get together and like talk strong
this is the kind of stuff that I think
about all the time not in this obsessive
way but it this enters my mind man
that's a good question - so basically
he's asking like okay and it happens for
literally half a second maybe one whole
second we're like okay man I need the
light on what do I do do I
you know like how he said do I reach for
it because that's the easiest way I
don't have to stand up use all my leg
and back muscles stand up and walk over
like just reach for it but if I can't
reach it now I got to expend all the
energy of reaching for it failing bring
the hand back and then doing the
standing up thing that I'd was trying to
avoid in the first place so it's one of
those things so what do i do man what do
I do
oh just chance it or do I just be like
yeah you know I'm not gonna chance
anything I'm just gonna expend the extra
energy and turn on the light so what do
I do
right yeah man it's a conundrum same
thing with the soy sauce pose same thing
also here's though here's one you might
did you see the meme yes there's there's
a couple there's a couple memes about
you in the soy sauce one of them one of
them was like a black-and-white photo
did you see that one I was like a
black-and-white photo but it said
something it was this black-and-white
photo of soy sauce bulls oh yeah yeah
what did it say I feel like the
strawberries or something like it was
better than the struggle is real yeah
and then they had the superhero looking
guy that had but two buttons yeah anyway
here's one and Bryan here's one that
this is this one's a real problem small
but a real problem for most yeah yes
when you're laying in bed at night you
see you're sleeping and you wake up
you're like man I gotta take it I gotta
use bathroom mm-hmm but not too bad I
don't have to use a bathroom bad just a
little bit so what do i do do I hold it
power through the discomfort because the
discomfort isn't that bad and hopefully
I'll fall asleep because I don't want to
get up and wake myself up more and turn
on the light and do all this stuff and
walk around get the blood flowing and
then what if I can't fall asleep as
quick or whatever or I'm tired I don't
even want to get out of bed you know so
what do I do
because if I go use the bathroom oh man
I'll be fully relaxed it'll be done I
don't it won't keep me up the discomfort
won't keep me up but if I can fall back
asleep I didn't even have to get out of
bed soon saying
so what do you do you're at that land
and if you really got to use the
bathroom is no issue because it's
obvious you know but if you just have to
a little bit it's a hard question
what do you I spend eight you guys zero
seconds
I spend zero seconds thinking about that
issue zero this is no factor whatsoever
unless the money do you're like I'm
gonna go use bathroom here's my here's
my answer to your question if I have to
go the bathroom I go to the bath what if
you kinda have to go to the bathroom no
there's no kind of yes therefore I don't
know no your bippy so if your bladder is
full
okay you got ease about the plenty for
you what if your blood is one-third full
then I don't have to go to the bathroom
okay so you have a distinct like cutoff
men in feeling so you don't have that
great area that I love you or I don't
all right so most of us we don't have it
like that no we gotta like consider you
know the same way that anyway anyway I
dig it and and that's gonna be one of
those ongoing challenges I think you
know I think the main and I almost left
that whole second half of the question
because the main point of the question
was the way you do anything is the way
you do everything
yes that's true to a point you should
definitely keep you know you try and
maintain consistent effort and hold the
line and everything but that economy is
that if you try and hold the line on
every single thing that's not possible
and you'd spend your whole life cleaning
up everything around you and fixing
things and what you just do you mean
wasting time when you have you need to
prioritize and execute pick the biggest
problems pick the biggest things are
gonna have the most impact on you and
then focus on those things and don't
worry about some other things yeah that
little conundrum is everywhere but
sometimes I'll be vacuuming and then you
know how like when you vacuum over like
I don't know let's say it's a piece of
big piece of lint you go over the vacuum
once you know and it doesn't go in you
go again it doesn't go he need to go I
could have picked that thing up like
three four seconds ago so why didn't you
cuz I thought I could have actually
could have got it with a vacuum and I
wouldn't have to bend down you know I
mean it's like that kind of stuff is too
old yeah its efficiency not laziness but
either way you know what though this guy
you combined with this guy's question
answered the question with how you do
everything you just establish a protocol
if there's a question you just do the
guaranteed one if I see a piece of lint
I'm a document they did show up bone
pick it up that's it under maybe I get a
double take right yeah general you got
to go forward and back on a vacuum
anyways you know what I'm saying you
just rerun that same track yeah because
you know you're going forward back but
you're you're offsetting a little bit
yeah and sometimes the back depending on
your brush depend on the back one over
the back one sometimes yeah more
powerful okay because the brush spins a
certain way interesting but either way
yeah good but either way too easy okay
no and then guess what on the forward
stroke you can go now to your next track
and you can bend down grab the piece of
lint you're good to go
done yeah so and the point is establish
a protocol where it's like you know what
I'm not gonna waste my time no you know
risking it and all this stuff I'm just
gonna go for the real deal all right
next question Jocko I'm a firefighter
slash EMT I recently and recently I went
on a call where a patient didn't live
not unusual by any means
unfortunately I deal with loss of life
on almost a daily basis I detach and do
my job always working to get better this
call I failed to detach it hit me hard
when the patient's husband let out a
chilling let out chilling screams as his
thirty year old wife went from alert in
talking to dead within minutes
I let myself enter into his shoes at
that moment I got over it quick during
my days off and moved on it's part of
the job and I accept that but my
question is when does it become inhumane
to detach do we sometimes need to let
some weakness through to remain grounded
when dealing with such major incidents
as loss of life thank you
okay first of all sympathy and empathy
are not weaknesses they're not
weaknesses in fact it actually takes
strength to be able to deal with these
types of the situations and these types
of emotions the weak move would actually
be to cut those emotions off completely
so that being said as you know obviously
the
is a dichotomy because you cannot let
the emotions overwhelm you as a matter
of fact if you get overwhelmed by your
feelings then you can't do your job
properly which in its own right is
inhumane because now you're not able to
treat the patients that you're trying to
save because you're getting too
emotional about it so what do you have
to do the answer for the for the
millionth time of a different subject
but comes up all times you've got to
find balance you have to find balance
between being emotional enough about not
being too emotional you have to learn to
recognize if you're going too far in one
direction or the other you have to do a
self-assessment you have to look and see
and make sure that the that you see the
people you're treating as people you
have to look at them and make sure that
you're seeing them as people that you're
not seeing them as a hunk of meat right
you have to do that you have to make
sure that you're doing that at the same
time you cannot afford emotionally to go
through the pain of loss every time you
see someone die because that's also
going to be a problem you can't afford
emotionally to do that you can't go
through that pain over and over and over
again so you have to like you said you
have to detach normally you do a good
job with that um I've seen guys get
wounded I've seen guys get killed I've
been around a lot of death and when when
it was around me I didn't have time to
stop and think about it I had to work to
do
I had to detach myself and do my job at
the same time when it's over and that of
time was appropriate it's like you got
to connect with what happened and make
sure that you are dealing with it
appropriately and you know I always
thank firefighters and paramedics and
EMTs and and police and military but you
know paramedics and EMTs you're only
showing up if someone is in a bad way
and I know that's hard physically and
it's hard mentally and it's hard
emotionally so
find the balance keep yourself balanced
make sure you're not going to farm one
direction or the other and thanks for
doing your job man that's like easy but
sometimes you forget that about EMTs
yeah fire friendly that's the only time
you know where they spray I mean pretty
much yeah no getting called because
someone is in a bad way that's the whole
thing what they're showing up for man
think you know cops too like like it's
easy to be on the outside when you're
going to parks and you know and if your
job is like you know I don't know me I
press record and make cool or make
videos or whatever you know and this is
like every day so it kind of forms this
kind of vision you know my world
whatever but EMTs and everything every
time you get the car it's just it's just
the question is just oh how bad yeah you
know that's what it is how bad how bad
of a situation is the person I'm about
to go content with what's their
situation yeah they are they could be
everything from a minor situation to
they're going to die in front of me
again again it's a new person will and
their life and their kids and their
family and you know Peter Tia talked
about some of that becoming a bit jaded
in fact it's a pretty horrific story and
it's worth listening to that podcast
when he was on and he talked about how
he got to a point where some patients he
started to look at I like Matt he'd be
mad at them
yeah mad at them and that's what you
have to avoid is getting to this point
you got to you got to do your best to
stay emotionally detached enough that
you can do your job but at the same time
you can't be looking at other human
beings as if they're just a piece of
meat yeah so
hard job I think we got time for one
more question I have good ideas but I
have trouble executing do you have any
tips I have good ideas but I have
trouble executing do you have any tips
oh yeah you have some good ideas do yeah
but you can't execute you you want to
know what those are those ideas are
worth when you don't execute on them you
know what those ideas are worth they're
worth nothing ideas by themselves have
zero value unless they can be brought to
life and I have known plenty of people
with plenty of ideas over the years
great ideas amazing ideas but very few
people can actually turn ideas into
action and those people end up old and
bitter and angry because they didn't
execute their great ideas and so here's
what you do you execute you actually
make things happen and sometimes I'm
gonna tell you when you execute your
idea it reveals the fact that your idea
isn't all that good it's not the
brilliant idea you thought it was and
some people are actually afraid of that
and that's what stops them but I'm not
afraid I say but bring on that failure
let me learn that my idea is no good
because even if you learned that your
idea is garbage at least you know not to
waste any more time dreaming about it or
thinking about it go on to your next
idea but don't let these ideas just
wander
around in your head get him out bring
him to life put him into the world run
with them and get some friends and
family or partners someone to help you
maybe get some people that are better at
execution than you are and give them
some ownership give away those ideas
it's better to give away those ideas
then let them rot inside your head and
die and whatever path you take whether
you force yourself to execute or you
bring people in to help you whatever
path you're gonna take do it do it pour
some life into your idea and like I said
you've got to remember that there's no
guarantee that when you pour life into
idea into an idea there's no guarantee
that that idea is gonna come to life -
you might pour everything you've got to
that idea and it can still die and you
might have to let it die you have to let
the dream die because some ideas aren't
good enough to live that's just the way
it is but but you know what at least
give it a chance
don't let that idea die inside your head
no more waiting no more putting it off
or waiting for the right time or the
right people or the right alignment of
things in the world no more of that no
more excuses just execution just go and
make it happen
and I think that's
all I've got for tonight so echo Charlie
while we are over here trying to make
things happen yeah so we have to go hard
we have to execute you've got anything
that could possibly help us execute yeah
our mission sure what do you got well
talk about origin first this is an
outstanding way to execute and maintain
the execution mmm so while we are doing
jujitsu
and you don't know what kind of ghee to
get yet which would be crazy but okay
people are starting every day and when
you start you do have that question most
of the time what's the maximum age for
starting jujitsu but Dad I think it's
the day before you die the day before
that maybe hundred or whatever yeah the
reason you don't start the day before
you die is you don't want to go to your
deathbed with regret because as soon as
you even learn a little bit of jujitsu
you'd be like dang I wish I would have
started that a month ago yes and had a
month of solid Jiu Jitsu yeah try and
learn what was happening yeah these
people were choking me yeah so yeah we
have people know all the time starting
to Jitsu all ages from four or five
below that yes you should return your
little kit should be trained you too but
it's more of a playful thing that you do
with them because you know the
techniques and you start having them
escape them out you start to have them
arm lock you what have them put in that
rear naked choke here to make sure you
tell them that the rear naked choke is
dangerous and not to do it if you're not
around cuz that is actually a scary
thing I used to I used to be a little
bit nervous about that when my kids were
real little yeah they know how to read
it with naked choke you know oh maybe my
five-year-old daughter
slaps a rear naked choke on my
two-year-old son right yeah and decides
you know to hang on to that thing cuz
crying or whatever so you got to be you
got to be very careful with that yeah
yeah that's a simple deal where it's not
like a you know a knife or something
where it's like hey this is dangerous
don't lean you know it's like it's a
little bit more cut-and-dry with the
rear naked choke it's kind of like okay
you have to do you have to deliberately
like apply the choke and
execute the chill for it to be dangerous
not like a knife all I'm saying is if
you got little tiny kids yeah below the
bike for two three four five yes you
teach them basic moves you need to
explain to them that the Moose are real
yeah and they do work and that's I I
always warn the little kids about the
ones kids are a little bit older they
understand because it happens to them
and they know what's going on yeah so be
careful with that part of jujitsu for
the little kids but whether kids are
four or whether you're 60 or 70 or 80
years old go get your jujitsu on gonna
need Agee Agee and or rest guard
actually knows beat and a rash guard
shack at least one check so what kind of
ghee origin ghee plenty to choose from
planning and be increasing by the as
time goes on straight up
all made in America and factually the
best skis in the world yeah and when you
buy an origin ghee you are you are
investing not only in yourself but
you're also investing in this great
country as we rebuild manufacturing
inside our country bringing back the old
New England factories that they sent
overseas we're bringing them back we are
actually bringing them back we are
buying equipment back from overseas
bringing it back here on ships
can you imagine that's happening right
now we are doing that you are doing that
you know you are making that happen
also we got genes here's the deal I
talked to Pete Pete Roberts she origin I
said Pete how many people do you know
that do jiu-jitsu and he's like 100 I
said how many people do you know that
own pair of jeans and he said 200
million I said we need to make jeans
everyone wants jeans everyone needs
jeans everyone would want jeans that are
not only high quality but also made in
America sewn by craftsmen in Maine so
yeah we got origin jeans they're awesome
we got Eric in denim
American denim like in cotton cotton
cotton yes yeah sown here later mean
something grown there you go
I'm surprised Pete Roberts hasn't come
up with that one yeah a grown and some
in America baby boom there it is but
also joggers speaking of pants jeans or
pants joggers don't get into the Joker's
here you're not allowed to do joggers
but for us who like comfort and
functionality
maybe I'll twist a style or whatever
there's some joggers on there why do we
keep bringing up joggers specifically is
it because of my experience with the Sun
right the joggers people like joggers
and you can also get supplements we have
supplements we have joint warfare we
have krill oil we have discipline we
have discipline and go according to JP
Danell when he takes discipline go he
can see people's thoughts like he was so
fired up he did you know an event fresh
L'Enfant he's like he's like I was so
fired up I could see people's thoughts
and I'm like I like the way that sounds
so discipline go little new trophic to
get the mind kicking and then you got
discipline for pre-workout krill oil
joint warfare keep the bones the tendons
ligaments the ligaments keep all that
stuff good to go
maintained onion flame so there's
inflammation what's the
anti-inflammation so keep them anti
inflamed and keep them moving keep them
lubricated keep them functioning very
important and in milk we got milk some
people don't even know what milk is and
it's really easy to explain milk is more
yeah it happens to have what 22 grams of
protein in their protein yes by the way
delicious which is different you know
and ambitious you have very delicious
and those I'll stuck to my friend Kenny
the other day he's like oh yes all about
this thing and I kind of got past I
detached you know I got happier get
emotional a little bit emotional but I
was like I started like going into this
whole pitch to my friend by the way it
was so it turned out to be a pitch but
just like how it's all clean and then
you know monk fruit to sweet man and
it's like doesn't taste like some day I
think whatever it's like a dessert at
the end of it I think
I think he accepted the beach the best
thing to do if someone wants to know
he'd get mixed one up yeah because when
as soon as you mix one up people like oh
yeah I'm older I'm getting this now
because how can this be good for you
yeah that's the question how can this be
good for you
yeah auntie's like that is true mint
chocolate peanut butter chocolate
vanilla gorilla darkness the child of
darkness and then there's this is uh
what I believe to be kind of epic
warrior kid milk yes because warrior kid
milk you can go to your grocery store
and you can buy something that will
flavor the milk so that your kids will
drink milk but while you're drinking
while you're giving the milk you're also
giving them poison yeah right
is sugar poison or is it not yeah you
can eat enough sugar that you die Yeah
right people do it all the time they get
Avitus yeah so we don't want to give our
kids poison we want to give them power
how do we do if you got more your kid
milk we've got strawberry and chocolate
they taste amazing they are engineered
the best possible food that your kid's
gonna eat
yeah think about it you can say oh you
want some dessert
and there get all excited here have a
strawberry milkshake boy and what do
they think thank you yeah can I have
more and you know what you say sure of
course you can you can have all you want
yeah because this is protein and
probiotics and vitamins
this is everything you're supposed to be
eating as a child to grow up and be
strong and a world beater all right
check yes okay also if you wanna stay on
the path and represent at the same time
attire wise chocolates door it's called
Jocko store so good a shock will store
calm that's we can get your t-shirts
more rash guards for the jujitsu and
it's good to have more than one rash
guard for multiple reasons one is that
if one gets dirty you don't have to rush
to wash it or rush to get it back in the
rotation necessarily it give you a whole
decision-making process you got a deal
with thoroughly problematic for Echo
Charles it's possible yes right you know
what I ran into and this is so
psychological so I were you know it
whatever I have a bond trash go yeah so
I get injured wearing this one rash card
I got won't wear it anymore
you think superstition yeah but here's
think I know that superstitious is fake
but you know what I'm super
superstitious about being no no I don't
care
yeah see fader didn't hurt you bro I
know I know exactly what hurt me that's
what makes it even worse either way
whether that's your are you gonna retire
the rash guard that you wore today when
we were training no no that no are you
sure no cuz oh yeah see I see what you
did there
know that none another white rash guard
award today was all good
it was the problem I had today was
psychological and it wasn't really
actually you were my problem straight up
you were my problem yeah I thought it
was funny though for all my jujitsu
career you know if I have a good role
with someone and I can die and I you
know do good against them a lot of times
they say oh you're really strong right
they never say like oh you got good
jujitsu they never say oh like I liked
your guard passing or hey you've got a
really good hip movement no they don't
say that
what do they say is you're strong yeah
that's what they say hmm today I got my
first kind of alternate compliment from
echo Charles you didn't say I was strong
no you said I psychologically destroyed
you yeah the whole thing okay so you and
you've been doing this kind of recently
where like I can't I don't even have to
be breathing hard but just maybe just a
little you like act you but like put on
this little charade oh I like or all
like push you or something even at all
man like don't say that but your body
will be like oh that push is so hard so
you'll do that and I know you're doing
obviously because you make it obvious
but then what that does to me is like
man that's like so you don't really take
me seriously right now so it kind of
makes not angry but a little bit like
frustrate cuz I want to do a little
something again sounds like and then
yeah then when you wind up like doing
things and then
kind of look at you and kind of feel and
then you do this real good normal face
kind of scenario and I think that I can
do good normal face too but on the
inside and I don't feel normal face you
know but all I see is like you're just
just being whatever making yeah it
doesn't look like just so you know on
the inside and the outside you don't on
the inside you don't feel normal face it
doesn't look normal the outside it looks
pretty evident what's happening well I
don't know yeah at the end of the day it
sort of just crept in and yeah I didn't
maintain the composure that I think is
required to function at a you know at a
better level than I did to put it that
way and the thing is right when the
timer goes off when we're done it like
it's like an avalanche of like
reflective it's a shame I always think
it's all part of the process no matter
how long and painful the process is did
you come in today with with a good
positive attitude on the what the
outcome was gonna be yeah do you feel
you were feeling good today yes so and
it just to be accurate like I don't we
always talk about this but I don't come
in thinking you're going charge whatever
I don't ever really thought about the
positive I'm sure about that I don't
think of that I know for a fact there's
been days where you've come in you I can
see it in your eyes you're thinking I
can do this today well not me well right
yeah I do think that yes I can do
sitting up and you kind of don't you
blow up out of fear you just trying to
convince yourself you're trying to be
like a cock right sometimes that happens
that's cool
I don't I don't hold it against you I
just accept it but sometimes you
actually think like today's the big day
and when I see that look yeah I think
okay well that's what I thought like
okay I'm gonna like beat up John it's
not that it's more that like I have a
hand thing is all you need to do is
capitalize on one mistake yeah that's
all that it is yeah you can just play
the numbers game now you know you know
you're good enough at jujitsu now if I
make a mistake you can capitalize on it
you can just you can just play the odds
I can beat you a hundred times and to in
I can beat you a hundred times or I can
tap you out no no we don't even care
doesn't even
doesn't mean don't mean anything you
roll the dice one time and you get snake
eyes you get the big win yeah that's
where it's at yeah but yeah sorry so
done not all good yeah it's like an
insurgent situation for sure yeah yeah
you can smash me all you want but it's
get you one time and devastate yeah but
it's and it's normally not like I'm not
necessarily trying to get it actually
most of time pretty much all the time
I'm not trying to like the goal is never
to have anyone out today it's not that
it's like to to practice new things that
I feel like I'm getting a hold of okay
against certain levels of people and
then so you're not me out well of course
I'm but that's not like the goal for the
day kind of thing it's more like okay
I'm gonna put together this like defense
and combine with this little thing and
whatever and for you it's real specific
cuz it's like rolling with you isn't
like this wha
it's like very specific scenario and
which in like includes the psychological
part yeah and that's why I noticed a
psychological devastation that you sort
of had today is because after the time
the timer went off we're done it all
came to me like men you just got
destroyed psychologically so bad that
goals that you had for that specific
role and for all roles with chocolate
today like who literally didn't have
anything to do with the role that you
just did me talking right now because of
like you're a whole mind stick mindset
you know and it was all because stuff
you're doing and here's a kind of the
dichotomy of it it's like super fun when
it happens but it's like the frustration
is like pushing yeah yeah but then it's
like at the end of the it's all just one
big game you know yeah but it there's a
legitimate a lot of frustration in there
for sure it's funny because I can see
that dichotomy in your face like I can
tell that you're mad but I can also tell
that it's fun you know but you do get
frustrated yeah at you oh so how did you
get legitimately like like you make
noises like frustration like groans or
growls you know what I mean
yeah but it's like at you know how like
and then you know what else you'll do
let's go again right now right
kid like a six-year-old the thing is
like fur and ice from the outside I can
see how that that could you know what I
don't know like you know what I don't
like is when I tap someone out mmm let's
say I'm in I'm in half guard and I tap
someone out with something and I let go
and then they're like then they want to
keep going like as if that just didn't
happen all from that exact position well
I didn't like that to me today yeah and
I was like I mean it's not it's not like
it's a big deal but I was I'm then I'm
like okay cuz you know I mean I I did
whatever move I did and then I let go
you tap and then I let go of it right
and then it's like well just keep going
yeah I don't know why I'm like what why
would we keep going you just you just
submitted yeah I and there's other the
other thing is sometimes people I think
you've done this to me like maybe 10
times no maybe 5 times where you tap and
then like I let go and then you have
come at me like you like you like double
leg or whatever you like grab and you
you know and that that's another one I'm
like oh okay yeah I see where I see how
this is going I think you're doing that
out of frustration yeah partially
partially out of like you understand
sometimes you want to learn what just
happened right like I put me back in
that position the cool part is yeah I
get that part too anything that kind of
bothers me I guess you know what though
at from an offensive standpoint like
from your position and someone's like oh
can we start from there it's kind of
like you know the flow it's like not
linear but you know the path of like
from start to finish that whole path is
like a big creative learning battle
fight wins losses like a it's a half I
think that's why it bothers me because I
like that whole yeah and a completed
half like yeah that whole thing of cuz
let's face it it's a big there's a lot
of things that go on there's a lot of
things that happen from from we start
rolling or you start rolling with
someone to someone submits there's all
kinds of things especially you're
starting standing you got a takedown to
contend with you've got guard passing
you've got guard recovery guts
we've got all these things to get to
this point where you can actually submit
somebody yeah and all of a sudden we're
just gonna skip 85% that battle which by
the way from my perspective all that
time all that battle is I'm I'm
maneuvering the whole time you know what
I mean like it's a part of my game it's
all part of me getting that submission
submission doesn't start when I hit them
at the submission it starts before we
shake hands you know yeah so when we
skip a big chunk of that I like that
whole part of the battle yeah so when we
skip it I just feel like oh that's kind
of weird yeah yeah you're right we just
jumped to the end of the good song that
has the guitar solo like yeah no you got
to listen the whole song yeah she ate
that thing yeah you're right a a good
movie right let's just skip to the scene
you know where the battle takes place
you have you ever done that you just
watch the battle scene that's not as
good as when you watch the hole right
there :
yeah I want to hear the whole I want the
whole build-up to take place yeah I just
want to watch the battle scene yeah
that's actually that's good and I'm
actually glad that we kind of analyzed
it because because it could be looked at
I always looked at it because I've done
that like I don't always do that know
you've done it probably five times we've
rolled thousands of times yeah and um
it's like okay can we start from there
kind of thing and I it's a little bit
different a little bit different it's
like hey can you just wait put that back
on me let me see if I could get out okay
you got out cool now we'll start again
right now talk about that yeah I'm
talking about what I did yeah today
where I was like I didn't say it but I
just sort of stayed there kind of like
let's kind of take it from here yeah
yeah yeah and I've done that before
really rarely but I looked at it as
shoot that was like a prot like I made a
legitimate mistake right there let me
like get back in that mindset and
continue actually rolling nothing that's
part of what bothers me yeah it's
nothing to me I think part of what
bothers me is I think to myself oh you
just made this little mistake and it was
kind of a fluke right that's what what
you're implying is like all this is just
a little fluke you were lucky that won't
happen again
that's like sometimes people get mad
when I submit them not very rarely and
I'm always like man is that this is that
in Seoul that I just have to out yeah I
mean yeah like I'm not when somebody
taps me out I'm not mad at them at all
I'm like dang nice job that was awesome
good job
yeah but yeah I think people are mean
anyway it's like any time law yet like
anything's out of frustration
it's literally like maybe a 30%
frustration seventy percent you're just
a guy that can take that kind of abuse
you know like if you're like okay good
you know you tapped me out and then I
you turn your back to reset and I yeah I
jump on your back or take you down
whatever like you can I won't do that
normally today no and even when you do
to me it's not like you you haven't ever
like jumped and like put a rear-naked
choke on or some like that yeah you've
kind of jumped into a slightly
advantageous but normal position for us
to be in yeah no big deal yeah you have
taken my back a couple times yeah but
and then even then like bro we've been
in this thing for a long time where it's
let's say I got it maybe that might who
would that even bother you let's say I
jump on you're backing in one of those
situations and I got the rear naked
choke yeah and I finished it yeah well I
would kind of be like well well we both
know you know like Friday can't you yeah
but um but real quick back to the the
path you know like when you when when
you want to like you have about any
wants to start from that same position
or whatever if you look at that path
that whole path that is so let's this
fit that's a valuable path every path
that you create it's like learning and
it's this big thing and it's fun there's
little competitiveness in there whatever
and at the end you finish each path as
like this tree or whatever it's done you
finish it with your submission when you
win or when you lose to in training or
even in competition you win or you lose
you can't like after you win and
complete your masterpiece path of wins
and losses that you know through the
whole thing and you're done that guy
just can't step in and be like no it's
not done it's just sort of paused on my
to it like right you can't jump in and
dictate that concern you lost brother
you're gonna start all over and try to
create something else no you know trying
to try new song can't just reader yeah
but at the same time if you're looking
at like training rolling as just
practice just training just you know
whatever
yeah there's a big difference between
hey we're gonna actually practice right
now you're right and we're gonna roll
yeah cuz rolling is understood that is
competitive that's the whole reason it
works so good it has to be competitive
so yes that's why when you tap me out I
do consider it no matter how much
percentage whatever I do consider you
beat me she's right up in practice in
training you beat me because there's a
significant amount of competition right
there
so yeah you can't be messing with
messing with the other guys wins and do
that yeah you're right I can't
I'm never doing that ever again if you
want to do it it's fine I'm just saying
not smell good not fine I'm not - noted
I don't wanna be that guy to do it even
that guy nonetheless back to
representing on Jacko's from chocolate
or chocolate stuff shirts and rash
guards and hoodies hats cool stuff
you're gonna represent on the path if
you okay so I made the new a new good
shirt I think it's on there yeah it's on
there mmm it's just it's good it's good
literally um says good on it with the
font and but it does not have your head
on it so it's way more basic cool you
know who that's the one where like you
really got to be in the know you see it
in in the wild it'd be like if you
listened you know yeah do you see the
dude that got good on his thumbs I think
it was his thumbs
oh yeah geo on one and OD on the other
and then I had to I dig it yeah in
proper font by the way yeah if you want
to represent on the path Jocko store.com
if you like something get something
whitey Chaka white tea available
drinking it right now from the can which
it comes in tasty and good for you and
also the teabags you can get that stuff
on Amazon and if you get it you can
deadlift 8000 pounds which is awesome
yeah so that's something also subscribe
to the podcast if you have it already
I'm just weirdness and leave it at that
if you haven't already hey subscribe if
you want you don't have to don't forget
about the warrior kid podcast just
released two new warrior kid podcast 22
and 23 get some questions for Uncle Jake
here's some stories from Uncle Jake
about when he was a kid I also got
warrior kids soap from Irish Oaks ranch
calm there's now trooper soap you know
with the rope with the ropes opener oh
yes
yeah so Irish soap French calm Aiden is
up there making soap on his farm and
what he wants us all to do they stay
cleaned
did you tell him and then now he wants
us to stay clean or you just sort of you
know imposing your tagline I am told I
dig it either way
also YouTube if you wanna if you're
interested in the video version of this
podcast or you want to just see excerpts
or whatever from the podcast get on
YouTube that's what you get is also
videos that echo perceives as very legit
because he made them right you're the
one who used we're legit check also
psychological warfare on itunes google
play mp3 platforms everywhere this is a
album where i can help you in little
moments of weakness get over that moment
of weakness and get yourself to stay on
the path
if you want something visual to help you
stay on the path
check out flipside canvas dot-com it's a
little company owned by my brother
dakota meyer podcast 115 by the way
absolutely an epic podcast to hear and
listen to and to be a part of with
dakota and we became good friends after
that and he's got this company flipside
canvas calm and he is making pictures
canvases posters that are cool and will
help you expand the path there's a
discipline equals freedom one there's
one that says good on it if there's
anything else you want let me know on
the social media and dakota will make it
happen take it
also when you're expanding your home gym
i'm gonna on it for your stuff rinks
jump ropes kettle bells primal bells
star wars kettlebells as well anyway a
lot of good stuff on there you got some
immune stuff for your immune
them some of there's a lot of real good
stuff on that go to on it calm slash
jockle really good stuff
also we got some books Mikey in the
Dragons Mike in the Dragons is about a
little kid that's trying to overcome
some fear and he does it by reading a
book the book is called the dragon
prince check it out Mikey and the
Dragons also weigh the warrior kid one
two and soon to be three that's a series
of books about a kid that's having kind
of normal trouble the kids have but he's
got an uncle uncle Jake who used to be
in the tames and he comes Celsus cousin
out there is yeah as cousin is his
nephew comes and helps his nephew out so
those are called away the warrior kid
marks mission and where there is a will
as book 3 also just poking equals
freedom Field Manual that's a book that
you need or it's a book you can give I'm
super stoked when I meet people and they
say yep I've given 28 copies of the
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
away to other people in my family are
the friends that I have why cuz it will
help people get on the path and live a
better life that's a powerful thing you
can actually help someone live a better
life there's a manual on how to live
your life it's called the discipline
equals freedom Field Manual it's not a
normal book it's not normal my publisher
when he was publishing it he said this
book is the biggest risk that he has
ever taken in his publishing career and
they he also said and were actually my
agent told me once the book came out the
book it the book sold more than any
scenario that they had predicted for the
book so they you know they do these
predictions of like oh if it tells us it
sells that it sells us thing sells out
it sells the other thing there's
something called a hundred percent
sell-through rate which means every
single book that got shipped got sold
this does not happen and then they're
back order and they had to make more now
the book is
still selling like that discipline
equals freedom Field Manual why does it
keep selling because people read it and
they get it for people they know so
check it out
it is the manual telling you how to get
on the path and stay on the path the
audio version of that book is not on
audible it's on iTunes it's on Amazon
music it's on Google Play and other mp3
platforms of course there is extreme
ownership the first book that I wrote
with my brother Lake Babb and about the
combat leadership principles that we
learned on the battlefield and how you
can apply them to your business and life
and we followed that book up with a book
called the dichotomy of leadership which
well some people are saying it's better
than extreme ownership read it judge for
yourself tell us what you think I think
if you read extreme ownership when you
read dichotomy a lot of things are gonna
fall into place
a lot of little level a lot of little
things that you didn't quite I have it
the way you wanted it to be when you
read dichotomy it's gonna come in a
place also we got national on front
which is our leadership consultancy we
solve problems through leadership that's
what we do it's me Lafe Babb and JP
Danelle Dave Burke Flynn Cochran Mike
Sorelli
Mike bimah and our latest addition to
the team Master Chief seal retired Jason
Gardner go to Ashland front comm if you
want us to come work with your company
the muster we got three musters this
year all musters ever have sold out
these are going to sell out well as well
there's May 23rd and 24th in Chicago
September 19th and 20th and Denver
December 4th and 5th in Sydney Australia
go to extreme ownership calm if you want
to come to these things just go and
register I had friends friends that said
hey you know I wasn't really signed up
can you just give me a couple tickets
and I'm like actually no I can't because
we can't fit any more people in the
building so no so I can't help you if
you wait too long
register get on and early on this is our
interactive leadership training if you
want to get everyone in your company
aligned if you want everyone in your
company to understand the fundamental
principles of extreme ownership if you
want them to understand the fundamental
laws of combat that we used on the
battlefield and that we have now taught
to scores of businesses if you want to
have that training you can go to EF
online it's interactive it's you have to
make decisions it's
choose-your-own-adventure its tests it's
it's briefings it's everything and it's
awesome so check out EF online.com also
EF overwatch where we are connecting
proven leaders from the spec ops and
combat aviation communities with
companies in the civilian sector now
here's the thing you might think well
I've got to hire somebody that's
experienced in this industry that's a
good thought I understand where you're
coming from what I recommend you try is
instead of hiring a person that has
experience in the industry have hire
somebody that has experience in
something more important that is
leadership you can teach them and they
can learn very quickly the industry that
you are bringing them into what you
can't teach someone and what you can't
give them as to 20 years 25 years 22
years of leadership experience in the
most high stakes business there is and
that is war so go to EF overwatch comm
if you want to hire someone like that or
if you are in that position of your vet
and you want to look to get placed into
a company that's looking for leadership
EF overwatch comm and if you want to
spend even more time with echo Charles
and myself because for some reason you
think 500 hours of podcasts isn't enough
for you we are out there we are lurking
on the interwebs on Twitter on Instagram
and on face book II Aloha echo is that
equals and I am at Jocko willing and
thanks to all the people in uniform for
your service
that's our military personnel also our
police and law enforcement correctional
officers border patrols all first
responders and tonight especially the
firefighters paramedics EMTs who face
suffering and death on a daily basis and
they learn how to handle it they learn
how to stay balanced they learn how to
detach but not too much thanks for all
of you for providing us the freedom and
security that we enjoy every day and to
everyone else that's listening you have
ideas and you have dreams and you have
vision and that's cool that's awesome
but none of that means anything unless
you execute so execute move forward take
action and you know what maybe your idea
works maybe it doesn't and if it doesn't
then try another one and maybe none of
them will ever work and that's fine
because in the end at a minimum you know
at least you went out there and got
after it so until next time this is echo
and Jocko out